pants go Braz - and you're welcome to
one of the classic games of the history
of gaming BMX xxx there it is
so excited to play this I play the
GameCube version and they have its intro
with a girl with you could see our
actual tits but I guess I guess they
censored either than the ps2 version I'm
a bit distant disappointed we're gonna
we can play as Ichi hello kitty
Wow Hello Kitty looks cool chill a ride
my favorite almost almost four armies
but Kristen Ryder wooden kissed him
ready to write her name in bold my
favorite I like this one
she's a pirate yar they all have nipples
showing through all of them I remember
when this game came out and I was a kid
and I was like holy [__] it's it's porn
but video games I was literally the
target audience it's kind of sad
underwear panties oh I can select the
weight nice nice
eyeball looks good let's go yeah oh that
is nice oh that's nice oh oh
going bold goin both make a trick oh god
what are you doing don't fart in my face
I love riding my bike yeah that's a
trick where the [__] did my bike go whoa
whoa whoa I drew better tricks than my
bicycle back flip I want to ride my
bicycle I want to ride my bike I went to
ride man
how the [__] do I talk to her oh oh
she's riding me what did she do ah she's
trying to choke me ah get it get the
process do it up how do I get it off get
it up yes
get out baby
Wow we're going to Disneyland it's gonna
be amazing front flip oh oh did you say
that you're complaining about our glutes
look at that oh my gloob crazy - did you
see that president miss Pressy deliver
the hookers to Fifi's hotel
Fifi's a challenge of course oh oh here
it is
it's that fat face hotel it's fifi so
tell that you can dude all you want baby
that's it now what is she doing
wait delivered her wow that was the best
job ever
you failed these hookers have customers
you know what you know what if that's
how it's gonna be if that's how it's
gonna be
come in come in come in I'm gonna send
that [__]
Jesus Christ scare the [__] out of me
the [__] is happen
oh my glutes man they're not okay this
like skate 3 all over again the
wonderful memories whoa whoa whoa
they're just back flop
I just [__] bat flopped back flip
yeah big flip yeah big flip yeah what do
you want sir this city don't pay me
enough to throw this [__] [__] dogs
are crapping all over that [__] place
I need you to get some from this guy I
know that get out
tell him big Lou she likes to ride fast
and fly high you know I'm saying shake
that ass up break my foot off in a foul
heretic better do what he says pick up
the poodle from the pimp
where the [__] is the portal ah there it
is [__] back oh my god it's a poodle
it's the poodle riding me I repeat it is
the pool is right but yes backflip
poodle flip Wow okay five seconds five
seconds I got it [__] let's do that
quest again come on Pony let's go baby
come on
I was hit by a car what the [__] is she
oh I got your poodle bridge all right
get the poodles scored twenty thousand
points then introduce the dogs twenty
thousand
who knew latency do you know how many
backflips that is that's a backflip
that's another backflip portal what are
you doing
pull it what pull what Oh God pull it
don't I'm so scared because he fight
great yeah spoodle nice one how am I
gonna do that merch in 20 seconds come
on all right we have 40 seconds to get
20,000 points come on portal baby come
on
make me proud baby portal we're gonna
score some big [__] points oh oh
we're not gonna nail it
there was a damn bootephant she's
already bumper up okay
she's already why did she horny okay all
right
that was that was BMX xxx thanks thanks
you like if you enjoyed one more
leave a comment and I'm gonna go
watching